We can consider a
given coordinate system
as a reference frame within
which we can describe
the kinematics of an object.
By "the kinematics," I mean
the position, the velocity,
and the acceleration
as a function of time,
basically a geometric
description of the motion.
Some aspects of these
kinematics will look different
in different reference
frames and I'd
like to examine that now.
First, I want to define what I
mean by an "inertial reference
frame."
An inertial reference
frame is one
in which an isolated body, one
with no net force acting on it,
moves at constant velocity,
where that constant velocity
might be zero.
Another way of saying this
is that an inertial reference
frame is one in which
Newton's laws of motion apply.
Recall that Newton's
first law of motion
states that an isolated object
with no forces acting on it
moves at constant velocity.
So let's begin by
considering an observer
in a particular reference frame.
We'll call that reference
frame S and denote it
by coordinate axes x and y.
And let's consider an object
that in that reference frame
is at a position vector small r.
We can then consider a
second reference frame, which
I'll call the frame
S prime, and I'll
denote that with coordinate
axes x prime and y prime.
In my example here,
I'm going to assume
that the coordinate axes in
frame S prime are parallel to
but displaced away from the
coordinate axes in frame
S. More generally, we could
have the S prime coordinate axes
rotated with respect
to the frame S axes.
That's a complication
I'm not going to add now
but conceptually, it's
not really different.
For simplicity, we'll stick to
parallel axes in this example.
So imagine we have
two observers, one
in frame S at the origin and one
at the origin of frame S prime,
both looking at the same object.
Observer S will measure a
position vector little r.
Observer S prime will measure a
position vector little r prime.
The two observers have a
relative position vector,
capital R, which is the
position of S prime relative
to the origin of frame S.
So what we'd like to see is how
are these different position
vectors related.
Well, from the geometry
of the diagram,
we can see that the position
measured by observer S, which
is just little r, is equal
to the position of observer S
prime relative to
observer S, which
is capital R, plus the
position vector measured
by the observer at S prime,
which is little r prime.
I can rewrite that if I'd like
to write the position measured
by the observer at S
prime in terms of what's
measured by the observer
at S. I could just
rearrange this and
write that little r
prime is equal to little
r minus capital R.
Now let's add a
further complication
and assume that the
observer S prime is not
just at a different location
from the observer of S
but is moving at constant
velocity relative to frame S.
So we'll assume that
frame S prime is moving
at constant velocity
with respect
to frame S at a constant
velocity vector V.
So V vector is a constant.
And in that case, my
offset of observer
S prime relative to observer S,
which is the vector capital R,
is a function of time.
So capital R is a
function of time
and it's given by the
offset at time 0, which
I will call capital R0,
plus the elapsed motion
due to the constant velocity,
which is capital V times time.
So since capital R is a
function of time, that tells me
that in this equation, little
r prime, the position vector
measured by the observer
in frame S prime,
is also going to be
a function of time,
even if capital-- sorry-- even
if little r is a constant.
So notice what that means.
If the object is
at rest in frame S,
the object will
appear to be moving.
Its position vector will be
time-dependent in frame S prime
because capital R, the location
of S prime relative to S
is changing.
So this relation tells us how
the position vectors in the two
frames are related.
What about the velocities?
Well, to compute how the
velocities are related,
we can just take the time
derivative of the relation
of the position vectors.
So in this particular
case, we have
that the time derivative
of the S prime position,
d little r prime dt,
is equal to the time
derivative of the position in
frame S, which is d little r
dt, minus the time derivative of
the offset of S prime relative
to S. So that's
minus d capital R dt.
And I can rewrite that in terms
of symbols for the velocity.
So I have here the velocity
little v prime, which
is the velocity measured by
an observer in frame S prime,
and that's equal to the
velocity of little v, which
is the velocity
measured by frame S,
minus d capital R
dt, which we see
is just capital V vector,
which is the velocity of S
prime relative to S. So this is
how the velocities are related.
And again, notice that if the
object is stationary in one
frame-- so if it's
0 in one frame,
it will be nonzero
in the other frame.
So in general, you will
measure different velocities
in the different frames, even
if one of those velocities is 0.
Now, how are the
accelerations related?
Well, again, we can just
take the time derivative
of the velocities
to figure out what
the relationship of
the accelerations is.
So differentiating
this equation,
I have that d
little v prime dt is
equal to d little v dt
minus d capital V dt.
But here, something interesting
happens because remember,
we said that capital V
is a constant vector.
And remember, capital
V is the velocity
that frame S prime has
relative to frame S.
So since capital V
is a constant, that
means that this term goes to 0.
And so we see that the
acceleration in frame S prime
is equal to the
acceleration in frame a.
So if I have two reference
frames, one moving
at a constant velocity relative
to the other, in general,
I will measure
different positions
and different velocities
for an object as
measured by the two frames.
However, the accelerations
measured in both frames
will be identical.
Because the accelerations
are identical,
we'll see that Newton's
laws will look identical
in the two frames.
And we can see that
in the following way.
In frame S, we
have that the force
is equal to the mass
times the acceleration.
In frame S prime,
the force F prime
is equal to the
mass times a prime.
But a prime is equal to
a, as we calculated here.
So we see that the
forces in the two frames
are identical, even though
the positions and velocities
in general will be different,
as measured in the two
frames for the same object.
But the accelerations
will be identical
and so the forces
will be identical.
So if one of these
reference frames
is an inertial
frame, one in which
an isolated body moves
at constant velocity,
then any other frame moving at
constant velocity with respect
to the first frame will
also be an inertial frame.
What this means is
that you're always
free to transform from one
inertial frame to another.
And what that means
is that you can always
transform to another
frame that is moving
at constant velocity
with respect
to an original inertial frame.